hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting
to something i saw in tik tok and i just
want to know if it's true
so you guys are going to watch me read
this article live
i found out on tech talk that
they're gonna allow a
biological male to compete in women's
sports
now i'm gonna tell you a couple reasons
i find this
if this is true offensive
so let me let me turn this off before i
read it
i was a d3 college athlete okay i played
basketball volleyball and i ran track
i love sports i was supposed to go play
in england i was gonna go play
basketball in england before my season
got cancelled
and i'm a center right so
if if our leagues were co-ed
i'm six foot that's tall for a girl not
so much
for a guy
my position like i wouldn't have been
able to play in college
i don't i can't keep up with guys
they're way bigger than me they're way
taller than me
like i can keep up with guys that maybe
played in like high school for
basketball but like
if they played in college and go against
me i would never
i would never win that fight so
assuming if this is true i don't know if
it was just clickbait or whatever
that would end women's sports for like a
lot of people okay
lauren hubble could become the first
openly transgender athlete to compete at
the
olympics she currently holds oceana's
continental spot for the olympic
qualification lauren hubbell is a
transgender weightlifter from new
zealand and she could very well make
history this summer
given her performance in the sport it's
likely that she'll qualify for the tokyo
olympics ahead of the may 31st
qualifying deadline the new zealand
olympic committee is keeping its cards
close to its chest
about the subject openly saying in a
statement
at that the organization is not in a
position to comment
on the likelihood of any athlete's
selection until we have no
the necessary evidence
oh so this is the olympic committee what
do you mean you're not
until you have the evidence of what
you don't think hubbard transitioned in
her mid 30s
so that's crazy you don't think
being a dude for 30 years would affect
your sport like this shouldn't even be
political
this will ruin women's sports if this
happens
like her act loads include a second
place finish
at the world championships in 2017 in a
six play finish
at the same competition in 2019 overall
she's ranked
16th in the 87 plus weight class for
olympic qualifying the way qualification
works in terms
of ranking is that the top eight lifters
are guaranteed olympic spots
and that each continent is given an
additional spot
for nations that don't have someone in
the top eight hubbard
has the additional spot for oceana by a
fair margin with a lifter from samoa
currently ranking 7th overall
weightlifting follows the international
olympic
committee's guidelines on transgender
athletes which allows those who
transition from male to female
if their total level of testosterone is
serum is below
10 nominals per liter for at least a
year additionally the athlete must be
keep their declared gender identity for
at least four years
after it's been declared
okay i'm i'm not a science person so you
guys can take this or leave it i'm not
gonna act like i know
everything about like the human body and
stuff
but this is what i do know let's take
basketball because
that's my sport if you're born
six seven six ten
seven foot as a dude and you transition
what am i supposed to do i'm like six
foot i know wnba players are tall
and stuff but men are stronger than
women
and i love i love women's sports
like i played it i i respect the hell
out of women's sports
but you're gonna let biological males
take spots that the women worked hard
for and essentially like
like that's and it's gonna be the top
spots you already know it
like okay japan announced that it would
extend a state of emergence oh
oh that's the next article okay
okay well it doesn't sound like it's set
in stone
i'm gonna look for another article but
i go back
wait wait is this it says fury over the
decision to let
okay a female a female
new zealand olympic weightlifter says
women complain about transgender athlete
lauren hubbell
competing in the tokyo games are being
told to be quiet
hubbard is on track to become the first
transgender athlete to compete
at an olympics after the international
weightlifting federation
modified qualifying requirements for the
tokyo games on wednesday
um but tracy something i'm not going to
say her last name
who also competed for new zealand and
weightlifting has said she believes
that hubbard competing in this war would
be unfair to woman yeah
she was a dude for 30 years
i i just i and this is coming from
someone
i play with guys i play basketball with
guys
like every week every week i play
against my boyfriend
i play against all these different
people
i have no doubt that women can compete
with some
man but
the top female athlete female athletes
are the ones that are going to suffer by
this decision
and especially like the tall girls
because if you're in a position like i
was where
what mattered for me in basketball was
my height and my strength
i'm not going to be taller than than a
biological guy i'm not going to be
stronger than a biological guy
i can't compete with that i could try
but like and i should preface not ever
some some guys i'm stronger than but
like
a guy that's like six foot same height
it's gonna be stronger than me
this is insane
ah this is insane
she doesn't even like look
like um
okay
okay the n-z-o-c can confirm that the
revised
international federation qualification
systems are very likely to see a number
of new zealand weight lifters including
commonwealth games transgender athlete
allocated if a quota spot for tokyo
2020.
many scientists have what about all the
people that say listen to science
many scientists have criticized these
guidelines saying they do little to
mitigate the biological advantages of
those who have gone through puberty as a
male
including bone density and muscle
density that's what i'm saying like
i'm pretty strong for a girl but that's
that's the thing
for a girl like i was
dead lifting in college close to 300
pounds that's a lot
for a girl but for a guy there's plenty
of guys that do that
and they're not even that strong like
how many girls dead lift
700 pounds
oh my gosh
this is i'm not even trying to be
political but this is outrageous there's
no reason
there is no reason that that should
happen let me know in the comments
if you guys agree with me or disagree
with me but
from my opinion as a female athlete that
is absolutely ridiculous
like
especially like women's sports have come
so far
there's so much more opportunity like in
2021
than there was like when i was growing
up like women are actually starting to
make a lot of money
they're actually starting like even
overseas like i have a friend that was
offered six figures to play overseas
that did not happen like 20 30 years ago
and now they're just gonna let the guys
take the little opportunity that women
have
very little this is coming from someone
like i was okay but i wasn't like crazy
good
so like i took
every single opportunity i had to play
and i could tell you there is not much
and so you're gonna give like the little
opportunity and like
chance to make money that women have
which which is very slim
you're gonna give that to transgender
athletes
it's ridiculous um let me know in the
comments if you agree disagree don't
forget to like comment and subscribe